more options becoming available for
people to get the vaccine
today the county opened its first mega
site to the public umc announced a new
location coming to the encore
joe mohler is live near the strip with
more on site information hi joe
hi there now that people over the age of
70 can get the vaccine we're learning of
more places
offering including the encore at the
wind behind us here this is being put on
by umc like you had just mentioned this
site will be open monday through friday
now the encore location will replace
umc's existing covid19 vaccination
clinic at umc's delta point building
we also learned boulder city has
announced it will start having
vaccinations as well they hope to do
1500 vaccines a week
today clark county's first mega vaccine
site at cashman center open to the
public
we spoke to donna armstrong she was one
of the first ones to get the vaccine at
cashman she says this is a step
in the right direction i feel very
blessed
i'm 74 years old and i don't have any
any other medical conditions at all and
i feel like the las vegas community is
doing really well
armstrong suggested people come early
and set aside enough time she was there
for
several hours clark county hopes to get
through 40 to 45 thousand vaccines a
week at cashman
with that site now open clark county
we'll look at other locations to
replicate that they are looking at the
las vegas
convention center to possibly be the
next mega vaccination site they're just
trying to work out the kinks there at
cashman first now a lot of people have
been having some issues with the website
to make an appointment
for the county's location such as
cashman well today we did get an update
from the southern nevada health
district they said that appointments can
only be made seven days in advance so
that no people are getting
that appointments aren't available until
february is just an automated
message reporting live joe mohler 8 news
now